morning in case you hadn't heard we
spring forward this weekend with the
return of daylight saving time so a lot
of folks
looking forward to the spring but we are
going to be losing an hour of sleep and
our hector mejia live with some
wellness tips to get yourself ready
hector are you getting ready to spin out
there what are you doing
i sure am hey there nate good morning
forgive me if i'm out of breath i've
been working out for 30
long seconds so it's time to uh
give this a break and this morning we're
talking about how exercise can help you
prepare ahead for daylight saving time
we all hate it when we lose some sleep
right so joining us live we have dr
zaki absal who's going to walk us
through all right so if we haven't been
to the gym for a while or maybe we've
been at home
not doing much how can you get back into
the routine
absolutely i'll give him the mic for
this demonstration absolutely
so the big thing you can do is you want
to pick exercises that you can probably
do at home
so the push-up variation is one of the
first things you can do easy way to work
your chest your shoulders and your
triceps
so if you haven't done push-ups in a
while a good way to do them is find an
elevated surface like a bench
or a countertop at home or a table or a
coffee table
and push down to your chest hits the
surface and you come right back up
so you want to do reps until you feel
some fatigue and as you work on this
over a couple days a couple weeks you
can start moving yourself
down to the floor again now if you wanna
start working your legs a little bit
more you can do
a lunge variation so lunges are easy to
do at home great for your for your butt
great for your legs and
for your quads and this is a full lunge
variation but say you haven't done these
in a while
you can do them to where your knees are
not touching the floor as you kind of go
down
so you're doing half lunges until you
get good at them and then you can do
full lunges again where your knees are
coming all the way down to the floor
the third one another great exercise for
your legs is the squat
so say you haven't squat in a little
while you have a little bit of trouble
you put a box or a chair behind you and
you go only down until you touch that
box of chair
and you come right back up where's my
box
so as you get used to it then you can do
a light hectare where you don't have a
box underneath you and you can go all
the way down
and back up and really work those legs
all right so it's important to keep this
in mind because you know you've heard
stories about people that get hurt when
they
try to go you know all hard again and
haven't been working on in a while
absolutely so the best thing you can do
when you first start working out is
understand that most injuries and pain
come from if you do too much too
soon so if you can do a little bit less
to start with and build yourself up it's
always better than starting
too far in and then having to back out
thank you very much so still ahead in
the next half hour at six o'clock we'll
be talking about how
a little bit more about how to prepare
ahead for daylight saving time
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
back to you guys
hector that's some good form they were
playing physical did he hear that yeah
they live in here i love it and that guy
is still doing push-ups it looks like
the music video where they're all
working out at the gym you know
that guy is still doing those push-ups